you
hi everyone is Gerry this is a short gem
from the 1959 candidates tournament
between Mikhail tal who's playing the
white side versus vasily smyslov let's
have a look
efore by tal c6 spiced me Slaven already
at this early point in the game let me
just emphasize if you're a tactical and
dynamic player and you play e4 and you
see this positional replies c6 the move
d3 on move to is something worth
investigating further it's noted as the
closed briar variation but don't let the
word closed detract you from knowing
that this position can certainly open up
and by move 7 in this game we get to see
a completely liquidated pawn center one
that is absent of both DNA pawns by both
sides and we arrive quickly at a
tactical and dynamic position one where
an emphasis on time and development is
super-important where we give less
consideration to material gain than we
do time and we really need to be
accurate calculators so following up d5
Knight d2 white wants to be in a
position to recapture on e4 with a pawn
and keep the Queen's on the board Knight
c3 would not allow this to happen
so it's Knight d2 e 5 9 f3 pressure on e
597 and now d4 I know that when I first
played the black side of this when I saw
this d4 move I found it a little bit odd
moved one step and then just a couple
moves later it's going to this d4 square
and clearly there's now a great number
or a great amount of tension in the
center we have from here D take C now by
the way instead of 97 if Bishop d6
defending here there is still this d4
move so either move that defends the e5
square can be met with d4 in other words
but in this case it's 97 d-4d take Z
night take seeing eat aches D Queen
takes D no pawns in the center emphasis
again time and development now let me
show you one other structural change we
could have at this moment where there's
a lot of options for both sides if
instead of D takes e we have e takes D
notice that this pawn is not throwing a
punch at a minor piece which is the case
with this capture so if he takes D we
don't have to take right away we can
instead take on d5 and after its
recapture now we take here and we're
playing against an isolated pawn on the
black side so if that's something you
like structure wise if you like to play
against an isolated pawn structure you
could go for that variation if black is
taking in this manner but in this case
it is d take Z Knight take C and then
the capture on d4 one other question I
had for myself when I was reviewing for
this game I had some concern about well
what if my Knights start getting kicked
around like f5 and then e for like where
will I be placing my Knights well keep
in mind that this move f5 it's a non
developing move this night is now
repositioning to an even more aggressive
square e for what is it it's an on
developing move it's certainly throwing
a punch at the knight but unfortunately
for black we don't have to be reacting
to these threats Bishop c4 simply
developing focusing on the weakness of
this f5 move there's Knight f7 around
the corner and just to emphasize how
badly things can get very quickly for
black if you take the knight we can
simply castle and if black is super
greedy and ignorant to his own King
being attacked and grabbing on g2 well
this is already a matin 6 in the
following way Bishop check Queen check
if King here this is game Oh
over night block we take the night we
develop the bishop we could give up the
rook who cares it's checkmate on the
next move Queen e6 and if it's defended
with Queen here or Queen here we give
made here so I just wanted to emphasize
that this kicking around this little
pawn roller will be shot down very
quickly so we don't have f-5e takes D
instead Queen takes D and now it's time
to develop Knight f6 Bishop g5 this
Knights in the pin pins are all the more
uncomfortable in open positions you
really want to have your pieces able to
move in open positions for sure so
development breaking the pin on the
knight queenside castle I really like
these queenside castle moves when
accomplishes two things in this case
King safety and rook activity this is a
completely open file sometimes you'd
even see this as a very good move if the
D file were only a half-open file so
after queenside castle black follows
suit with the King sight safety Knight
d6 one of the most annoying positions to
have a knight and the d six square here
your sixth rank your opponent's third
rank very annoying piece hitting at a
lot of points in the black position
Queen to a5 you may think by the way
that this Knight is looking to pick up
the bishop pair which might not be a bad
idea but he has other annoying ideas
there's a square that may very well be
even more annoying than d6
we'll soon see that so Queen a5 she has
some lateral influence and she's
pointing at a2 so how do we solve that
we develop and defend we are now as
white fully developed direct contact
with the rooks and now b5 so how do we
replay or how do we reply to this move
well
it's clearly a very open position light
has other pieces working we don't
necessarily have to react to our
opponents threats we can maybe get in
the habit of first looking to simply
ignore the threat and try to come up
with something that's even stronger so
scanning the position we could be
looking for checking moves we could be
looking for ways to attack pieces that
are even greater than our Bishop on our
opponent's side and also doing a scan
for unprotected pieces so in other words
I'm talking about is there way to maybe
throw a punch at the Queen or any of the
rooks or is there a way to attack an
unprotected piece the bishop okay there
are ways to do this and the one that
Tolly Lex is first Bishop to d2 hitting
the Queen this is also freeing up the g5
squared we'll see how this is
influential there's a piece that ends up
making use of the g5 square the Queen in
fact and this Bishop is also has another
intention and that is to reposition on
c3 and hit right at the heart of the
black structure g7 so after Bishop d2
Queen a6 this Bishop is still under fire
but it is once again ignored he's in
between moves Knight f5 striking at an
unprotected piece and looking to do so
looking to capture with check if pawn
takes Bishop Knight takes bishop with
check in the game we see that this dark
square structure over here these dark
squares near the Kings side come under
some heavy fire and there's some
interesting tactics that show itself so
you could just imagine how much more
devastating it may very well turn out to
being on the black side without their
dark square Bishop around so we don't go
down that line black is not so quick to
give up their dark square Bishop Bishop
d8 instead Bishop c5 is maybe
one of the top moves to be considering
because you really want to try to meet
attack with counter-attack Bishop d8 is
primarily a just a defensive move or
just a retreating move not throwing
another punch at the white side what
might happen if Bishop c5 is played well
what could follow is Queen h4 this
Bishop can be taken and now we have the
move Bishop c3 and the black needs to be
super careful despite being down a minor
piece White has a lot of pressure on the
heart of the King side structure g7 in
particular and if this pawn ever moves
look at these squares f6 and h6 I was
pointing out the knight on d6 can be
quite inconvenient but the knight on f5
since he's on the same color squares the
opposing King he's within checking
distance isse evan h6 and even the idea
to rip that pawn from the g7 square
really should be coming to mind so very
annoying the knight on f5 after Bishop
c3 if Queen takes a - we could have
Knight h6 check if pawn takes Knight
this is going to turn out very badly for
black we can remove one of the defenders
of f6 and we're going to be winning not
long off from here there's really not
much that you could be doing this is
apparently best Bishop to b4 if
something instead of Queen a1 if like
this we have Queen takes f7 and it'll be
game over soon enough so I just wanted
to emphasize that particular line and
also this one here after Knight h6 what
about King h8 well we can actually take
this night on d7 if he's recaptured this
is not best but I just want to emphasize
again these little tactics involving the
night in the bishop and the g7 square if
pawn takes that's a cube mate so a lot
of dark square pressure in other words
when you have two
or more pieces converging on one
particular square whether it be directly
or indirectly you really should be on
the lookout for tactics Knight h6 9
takes g7 97 stuff okay but we don't get
there doing instead of this Bishop to c5
move it was Bishop d8 this Bishop is
still under fire b5 came at move 11 move
12 move 13 move 14 are ignoring the
threat ignoring this idea of reacting to
potentially material loss and instead
repositioning the Queen to a more active
square looking for this Queen g5 move
the bishop is finally picked up black
goes for it Queen g5 threatens mate how
do you defend that Knight h5 if g6 while
this is weakened in your position Knight
h6 King g7 would be best and I'm not so
sure this is how the game would finish
but if white if white wanted to at the
very least there could be this perpetual
check if the King went elsewhere such as
King h8 this is going to be big trouble
here the bishop being opposite there's
already ideas of taking out the knight
taking on f6 ok but we don't have that
after Queen g5 it's not g6 but instead
Knight h5 defending g7 this was the
other way to do it but keep in mind you
are dropping your bishop so it's Knight
h5 and now what do we do here this is
defended our queen is hit so clearly we
take the knight right we don't yet again
we need to be very accurate move order
is super important if we take the night
this night place to f6 hits the Queen
and what follows well the number one
annoyance on the black side the knight
on f5 is removed and it is black who is
all of a sudden winning having defended
their King side well enough
this night could be very annoying
getting into E for potential Forks on f2
and maybe right around the corner this
Queen is going to smash through on a -
and look for me black is winning from
this position so we need to be careful
after Knight to h5 we don't just scoop
the knight up we take advantage of the
fact that this pawn for this just this
moment is pinned Knight h6 King h8 is an
only move and only at this point do we
grab the knight
okay so following up we have Queen takes
a - if pawn takes Knight this is going
to get destroyed Bishop c3 if Bishop f6
Queen takes h6 this Bishop is pinned the
main threat here is Knight to g5 this
Queen is super active hitting out a ton
of squares in this quadrant of the board
nearly half of the squares are hit
directly with this Queen on h6 Queen h6
if Bishop takes Bishop Knight g5 this
can only be parried for so long
Queen takes h7 if Knight here we have
Queen takes rook Knight block some other
inmate or just knight takes f7 is mate
so we don't have that we don't have at
this point pawn takes Knight Bishop c3
would be the follow-up but instead Queen
takes a - looking for mate on a one
light sees this of course Bishop c3
points at the king pins the pawn has a
square now open for the King to run - in
case of Queen a1 there's King d2 which
would then be a counter-attack against
the black queen Knight to f6 is
unfortunately at this point
losing move a better move instead of
Knight to f6 would be Bishop to f6 and
at this point we can now have Knight
check King g8 knight on f3 to g5 looking
for made on h7 but now white or excuse
me black has a very nice reply Queen
King to d2 Bishop takes Bishop with
check on takes and now what do we do
here as black there's not only the
threat of checkmate but the threat of
rook takes Queen how do you defend both
well fortunately there is this key move
Knight f6 hitting the Queen defending
against me and well if rook takes Queen
Knight takes Queen and if the White
Queen runs away well the black queen is
going to run away and this will be hold
a bowl for black as dangerous-looking as
these Knights are in this Queen next to
the black King this Knight is a super
defender on the f6 square so instead of
Bishop f6 which is which was the best
defense we had Knight f6 and this is
where we have the following winning move
here so if you'd like to pause the video
see if you can find
Tawes reply at this point okay the
winning move here is Queen takes f7
simply looking to grab the rook leading
to mate with the Queen takes Knight and
then maybe even some smothered mate on
f7 the idea here is that if rip takes
Queen we grab the bishop with check you
could block like this we grab the rook
you can block like this and we have our
pick rook takes knight or maybe the more
aesthetic one night f7 mate so we don't
have rook takes Queen at this point
instead in the game Queen a1 king d2
only now is the Queen taken we don't
take back just yet Knight takes rook
with check King g8 now we pick up the
Queen King takes Knight and soon enough
after the smoke clears what do we have
ninety five check canny sev King de six
like grabs upon black throws in a check
but this is going nowhere if we do just
a quick body count here we have wiping
up the exchange after this check Bishop
to d4 simply blocks it welcoming more
exchanges good strategy when you're up
cereal and it's at this point that's me
Slav resins there's nothing really to do
one quick variation might include 95
there could be 95 looking to grab this
pawn bishop b7 you could be grabbing
here if black is super greedy trying to
hang on to everything well it's just
running into more problems Bishop here
you just backup family grab here there's
no worries of any discovered checks
because you're taking out the bishop if
the knight moves but as it was in this
game after simply Bishop to d4
it's me Slav ends up resigning so very
interesting tactical game just 26 moves
in but a lot of precise calculation
needed an emphasis on move order and of
course time and development when it
comes to open positions so that's all
for this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye after
e3 I believe it's already an important
point in the game I bring this up
because if you're playing is black and
running with the routine Bishop g7 I
believe you would be neglecting the
center